[Music]
yo
rob hello my name is dance i'm from
seattle i'm calling you from assumption
paraguay
where i am a teacher
a really great teacher an award-winning
teacher
i gave myself the awards
but anyway
i have a question for you roblox
what
was rob lopes secrets
actor to work with
and why
thank you roblox
well
hello from paraguay i love it's an
international podcast i've been telling
everybody
you know or it's it's far-ranging our
audience
um
my favorite actor
that's so hard to say
you kind of gotta go with your instinct
and the first thing that pops up because
the truthfully i've worked with so many
great ones
that it would be tough but i
pound for pound just acting
i think it's alice and janie
she's got technique she's got charisma
she can be funny she can be dramatic
she
is not showy you know when you watch her
work it doesn't look like she's working
super hard at it it all seems super
natural and easy
she's got kind of got ticks all of the
things that i like stylistically in in
in an actor and um and
also a great person
um and listen let's face it um as i hear
myself talk it's not that bold of a
choice i mean she's got
an academy award and she's got 75 emmys
so i'm not
you know i'm not alone i think i'm going
with the the great allison gianni thanks
for for calling in appreciate it hello
to paraguay